well I think the I've worked in the
earlier periods three to four million
years ago what excites me probably more
than anything these days is the
emergence of ourselves the emergence of
anatomically and behaviorally modern
humans for many years we've thought that
this was an explosive moment it was
called the the cultural explosion or
whatever the cognitive explosion and
what we're beginning to find is that it
is a sort of step-by-step development
and most of those in important steps
were seminal in Africa and I I think
that we're going to be able to flesh out
in much more detail the archaeology the
paleoclimate the biology and the
behavior of the emergence of that
creature those creatures early Homo
sapiens that gave rise to all humans
today and it is my sense that all humans
today come out of Africa so by
implication regardless of what we look
up look like on the outside genetically
on the inside everyone is an African